remember we introduced or at least we
labeled this guy this of course is a
triangle yeah me no shakes okay this is
a capital Greek letter Delta and the
Delta stands for discriminant so in a
quadratic function this is how we
calculate evaluate what the discriminant
is and the discriminant is called the
distributive because it discriminates
between the various kinds of quadratic
functions if the discriminant positive
ones that talk about the quadratic
trotty roots very good or you could say
it's got distinct real roots if the
discriminant is exactly zero what does
that mean one equal one root or or two
equal roots okay and if on the other
hand the descriptives negative that
means no roots
okay now excuse me we're interested in
this because roots are very important to
a quadratic but we're done the only
thing and the discriminant can help us
understanding classified quadratics even
when you're not really thinking about
the roots and these classifications are
what we've got up here okay so what I
want to help you understand is let's
draw some pictures underneath this can
you draw for me
let me count them one two three small
sets of axes three small sets of axes
just beside each other is fine
we're not going to do we do any labeling
here we just want to get some pictures
excuse me
so let's think about those situations
for a minute we'll do them in reverse
order if the discriminant is negative
you told me that means there's no roots
okay so for instance such a quadratic
could look like this that would have a
discriminant is negative or
alternatively it could maybe look like
this that will also have a negative
discriminant no roots or no real roots
anywhere okay so this situation over
here is discriminate less than zero now
what is it that makes a parabola the top
one or the bottom one concave up or
concave down it's always about the a the
B and C matter but not in terms of
defining the concavity right we know
what C does all it does is move you up
and down right the B I'll let you I'll
let you fiddle in desmos to experience
this for yourself it's much better but
the B sort of slides it around in a both
horizontal and vertical way but a is the
only thing that tells you where you're
facing up or facing down okay so in this
case up here you've got a positive value
for a concave up whereas for this guy
down here you've got a negative value
okay now let's look at the top one if
your discriminant is negative you've got
no roots if a is positive it's concave
up every value that this quadratic
function will give you no matter what
input you supply every output will be a
positive number
do you agree all above the axis okay so
therefore we call this guy a definite
quadratic and it's all positive so it's
positive definite so let me write that
down for you this guy up here
is called a positive definite quadratic
because every value every output you'll
get out of that will be definitely
positive and likewise you can probably
Majan what's this guy going to be called
not positive negative definite but
negative definite because the matter
what x you put in
your y-your output will be negative so
it's definitely negative okay now then
what happens when you have a look at
other values for your discriminant so
for example I could say something like
this or something like this right so
what value would you have for the
discriminate in these cases the
discriminant would be negative it would
have to be positive to be one of these
situations okay in this case depending
on what input you supply you will have a
different value for the output it could
be positive or it could be negative it's
not definite which side you'll get
because it changes so therefore instead
of calling it this definite or that
definite we call it indefinite because
there could be either is definite now
I've got negative discriminative
discriminant is one life situation zero
discriminant might look something like
this okay so this is prescribing it
equal to zero you can see the one root
that there or the two equal roots now
how would you describe this it's
tempting to say the left-hand one is
positive definite it's tempting to call
this positive definite because it
certainly looks like it's all above the
axis except for one teeny little problem
what's the teeny teeny little problem it
touches the axis wrong color it touches
the axis right there and zero is not
positive right in the same way this guy
over here touches the axis and zero is
not negative so it's not positive
definite because not every single value
is positive even though it sort of looks
more like this than like this this
really is also indefinite so we could
combine both of these together and see
if the discriminant is greater than or
equal to zero you have an indefinite
quadratic you need a negative
discriminant
they have all positive or negative
values okay